[Música]
muy buenas tardes muchas gracias por
estar acá todavía
también muy agradecido con los
organizadores por darnos la oportunidad
a todos ustedes principalmente y al
ministerio de educación pública de tener
un evento de este tipo que refuerza
nuestras convicciones
la circunstancia sobre la que voy a
hablar convive con nosotros desde hace
muchísimos años
concretamente cada uno de nuestros
estudiantes los que estuvieron hoy en la
mañana y en la tarde en aulas de
escuelas y colegios tiene dos conocidos
o dos familiares muy cercanos que algún
día estuvieron en las aulas y no
terminaron
yo creo que mi mejor y mayor aporte esta
tarde después de que ustedes hayan
escuchado voces robustas sobre
experiencias no es plantear sobre no es
plantear una experiencia que ya vivimos
sino una que deberíamos de vivir
qué tiene que ver con cómo ponemos los
ojos sobre estas personas con qué mirada
nos cobijamos si hay mirada para
cobijarlos o no
invariablemente los seres humanos
tenemos la necesidad y la voluntad de
incluir nos la necesidad porque es de la
inclusión de donde conseguimos nuestra
competitividad individual
y la voluntad
porque al incluir nos encontramos la
posibilidad de desarrollar esta
habilidad que viene con nosotros que es
la de colaborar y cooperar y esas dos
hermanas también nos acercan al amor
cuando uno habla de las personas que han
quedado excluidas en el sistema a mí por
lo menos me viene a la cabeza está
maravillosa saga que vive en una pequeña
avispa y el higo
los hijos forman parte de una familia
muy extensa de árboles de más de 700
miembros
y tienen una particularidad todos ellos
y es que son polinizados por alguna por
algún polinizador específico
especializado en ellos y es el caso de
los hijos en el caso de los hijos el
polinizadores una pequeña avispa casi
diminuta imperceptible a la vista
pero muy poderosa
otra particularidad de esta simbiosis de
esta saga es que el higo no es una fruta
el higo es una flor es una flor
introvertida es decir es una flor
que nos permite proteger los pétalos y
crear alrededor
una textura dura que la hace parecer una
fruta sin embargo lo que sucede para la
polinización del higo es que
la mamá de las avispas deposita los
huevos
nacen adentro del higo y cuando se
aparean
los machos empiezan a buscar el cielo
taladrando el higo de adentro hacia
afuera
hasta que logran perforar la cáscara
vamos a decirle así y eso le da
posibilidades a la hembra de que
trascienda la flor y busque otra flor a
veces kilómetros de distancia guiada por
el olfato pero el macho al taladrar el
higo pierde las alas
y cuando llega la hembra a la otra
higuera y encuentra otra flor repite el
procedimiento pero al revés de afuera
hacia adentro y en ese proceso de
taladrar hacia adentro para depositar
sus huevos y cumplir la promesa de la
polinización también pierde las alas
nuestros estudiantes inactivos les vamos
a llamar así dos millones de personas
son como la avispa del higo
solo que pierden sus alas dos veces
cada una de ellas una cuando salen del
sistema y otra cuando intentan regresar
este modo de des considerar los de no
tenerlos en cuenta de no poner los ojos
sobre ellos es más motivante que
cualquier otra cosa
nunca hay una mirada sobre sus talentos
habilidades y competencias adquiridas en
ese camino paralelo que han seguido al
canal central
que nosotros si consideramos un proceso
robusto de educación
y resulta que de esto
tenemos datos
de los muy pocos que se matriculan de
vuelta es decir que vienen a perforar de
adentro hacia afuera 75 por ciento
tienen entre 16 y 25 años
pero noten se la caída del porcentaje
cuando cumplen 26 años y entre 26 y 35
sólo un 15% lo intenta a los 26 años
pierden la fe en el sistema
y el niño que cantaba dudas a la
educación se vuelve contra ella
afirmando que esto no sirve para mucho
y a lo sumo es un obstáculo en su vida
nuestros estudiantes inactivos son como
las avispas del hijo pero pleno de
derechos
de derechos constitucionales
para ellos y ellas ese derecho fue bueno
para entrar al sistema pero no para
terminar y me pregunto cómo se llama
entonces un derecho universal que deja
las cosas a la mitad
será un derecho universal parcial será
un derecho universal
truncado
cómo y por qué hemos llegado a esta
antinomia
a ese abismo entre la teoría de lo que
somos y la práctica de lo que somos
volvamos la mirada al elefante y a su
estaca para desenvolver una hipótesis
los constituyentes de 1869 hace 150 años
recogieron la experiencia política de 11
años de aplicación de una ley que hacía
obligatoria gratuita
y para todas las clases sociales la
educación de niños de 7 a 12 años
ya sabían que la educación si podía ser
la columna vertebral de un sistema
político y amalgamar una nación
pero sobre la educación en sí dieron por
buena lo que había
y esta era una educación lancasteriana
que dicta desde una cúspide de autoridad
que la letra sin sangre no entra
es decir una educación autoritaria y
castigadora
en contraposición don jornal don arnoldo
herrera fundador del castella y
practicante de otros métodos educativos
decía de esa educación que era como una
flecha que atacaba al estudiante
yo diría que una flecha que además se
clavaba en el piso para muchísimas
personas y constituía después esa estaca
a la que el elefante está atada
con una pequeña cadena
pero porque el elefante poderoso
poderoso como ese subordina a una estaca
pequeña
esto me lo pregunto cuando miro este
fenómeno desde los ojos de un escolar
y la respuesta es porque ha estado atado
allí desde pequeño
y alguna vez intentó librarse de la
estaca pero no tenía la fuerza
suficiente para hacerlo
se agotó haciéndolo y haciéndolo y no
lográndolo
aprendió
su impotencia
y convirtió su impotencia en un dogma
personal
puede un país marchar bien con estas
contradicciones con estas injusticias ha
sido la educación una matriz de igualdad
o de desigualdad
no no puede un país marchar bien
el diseño determina el resultado
mientras la educación en costa rica
desestime a sus estudiantes y no ponga
la mirada sobre ellos mientras sea un
artefacto autoritario como una flecha
lanzada desde arriba recto irremisible
seguiremos teniendo esta circunstancia
que nos hace ver mal en el espejo de
nuestros derechos y de nuestra civilidad
seguiremos hablando un tren con tres
vagones en el primer vagón estamos
nosotros y otros dos millones de
personas en el segundo vagón están los
estudiantes que son considerados así
por el sistema educativo autoritario
estudiantes pequeños niños y jóvenes y
en el tercer vagón están los excluidos
los excluidos de la educación
pero qué pasa que no cambiamos incluso
luego de ser discípulos de bigotes kings
de howard gardner de paulo freire de
bloom
qué pasa con nosotros que a pesar de
tener un mandato para desarrollar una
experiencia didáctica y pedagógica
fundamentada en el desarrollo de
habilidades para la vida
no logramos encontrar un modo de ayudar
a quienes se han quedado atrás mi
hipótesis es que seguimos muy activos
casi por inercia organizando nuestra
oferta
cuando fue que salió en octavo
pues bienvenido por el mismo hueco que
te fuiste tenés que regresar ahí está tu
pupitre doctor
organizamos la oferta pero no la demanda
la demanda diría pero no hay manera de
que me reconozca que yo tengo
habilidades competencias que yo he
sacado adelante dos hijos que tengo un
trabajo desde hace 11 años
que soy perfectamente competente
en el marco de tener habilidades para la
vida
si a estas personas no les ponemos los
ojos encima de verdad
para ofrecerles un reingreso digno
seguiremos perdiendo los constantemente
una y otra vez
todas esas habilidades y competencias
que ellos tienen son perfectamente
compatibles con las que promovemos en
nuestras políticas educativas
si tan solo los observamos por unos
minutos
por una hora
si los observamos metódicamente si
observáramos a catherine la mesera o
alan el sin título que maneja el
recursos humanos en oficina o a
carlomagno que era fatal en matemáticas
pero ganó un grammy como músico
solo
si los viéramos de verdad no veríamos un
elefante sometido a una estaca
veríamos de cambio polis
veríamos poli gris que se levantan
firmes a pesar de que están volando
cálculo no calcula el colibrí cuando se
acerca a la flor
es una pregunta técnica
y la hago con honestidad calcula o no
calcula el colibrí cuando se acerca a la
flor
claro que calcula
podríamos pedirle al colibrí que nos
explique cómo calcula a través de una
ecuación un algoritmo pues podríamos
pedírselo pero no lo haría
podríamos reconocer que de esa habilidad
que el colibrí tiene es una habilidad de
cálculo depende su vida y la ejerce
todos los días no solo a favor suyo sino
a favor del planeta aportando más de lo
que nosotros somos capaces de aportar
que es su habilidad que es su habilidad
particular
la que le da la vida podría calcularse
esa habilidad si podría calcular la
quien lo evalúa también
la transformación de nuestro sistema de
evaluación para que sea congruente con
nuestra currícula y con los desafíos de
nuestra sociedad ya está en marcha
un faro para adultos es lo que sigue
ese faro pondría luz sobre las
habilidades
de quienes han caminado por fuera de
nuestro sistema y han recorrido su
propio camino acumulando conocimientos
saberes que son útiles para la sociedad
y deben ser reconocidos por la educación
y a partir de ahí podría
imaginarse todos ustedes y les ruego que
lo hagan
un conjunto de caminos diversos para
estas personas
que no son
el expediente fácil de regresé a octavo
año que es de donde usted salió
que parten de la idea de haber puesto
los ojos sobre ellos de haber entendido
lo que traen
y no tratarlos como los tratamos como si
no tuvieran nada que ofrecer
aprovechemos que tenemos una fuerza
curricular nueva aprovechemos que la
mitad o más de ustedes
pertenecen a otra escuela de formación
que todos ustedes son profesionales del
cambio de la transformación que
invariablemente una maestra y un
profesor si algo es
es el artífice del cambio el artífice de
la transformación social y pensemos cómo
ayudamos a estas dos millones de
personas que se han quedado atrás o tan
siquiera a algunas de ellas a más de ese
7%
que se acerca a todos los años con una
gran esperanza y del cual sólo un 5%
culmina después de un esfuerzo repetido
de más de 7 años
resolvamos esta injusticia
planteamos la posibilidad de reunificar
el país
planteándonos la hipótesis de que quizás
el país está dividido porque la
educación
la ha dividido
en ellos y nosotros
planteamos la posibilidad
maravillosa de no solo cooperar con
nuestro grupo con nosotros sino también
cooperar y colaborar con ellos
yo soy ministro y tengo algunas ideas
pero ya lo dije hace un año seré un buen
ministro si escucho las ideas de los
demás
si alguien aquí quiere compartir conmigo
las suyas para ir atrás y recoger a
costarricenses que se han quedado en ese
tercer vagón cuenten con mi interés
lo que doy por cierto es que no podemos
seguir diciendo que no dejaremos a nadie
atrás mientras ya dejamos atrás a 2
millones de personas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]